[Musik]
guten abend liebe zuschauer
donnerstagabend sie sind sie wieder mit
dabei das ist gut so die waffen
schweigen nicht dafür aber die
unterhändler die gespräche zwischen der
ukraine und russland wurden abgebrochen
wie lange soll dieser krieg noch dauern
die ukrainische regierung hat eine klare
antwort solange bis alle russischen
soldaten vertrieben sind ein legitimes
ziel aber auch ein realistisches olaf
scholz sagte heute einen diktat frieden
dürfte es jedenfalls nicht geben und
frankreichs präsident warnt davor
russland zu den nötigen wie einig ist
der westen das fragen wir uns und diese
gäste
ursula von der leyen präsidentin der eu
kommission
gregor gysi außenpolitischer sprecher
der linken
der militärexperte gustav dressel
aus kiew zugeschaltet die autorin und
fotografin jewgenia beloruss es
der spiegel autor markus feldenkirchen
und marie agnes strack zimmermann fdp
die vorsitzende des
verteidigungsausschusses
sie sind zu gast bei maybrit illner
[Musik]
herzlich los geht es jeder zuschauer was
kann die ukraine erreichen und was will
der westen
anfangs noch zurückhaltend hatten die
usa inzwischen den druck in sachen
kriegsziele erhöht
wir wollen russland in dem ausmaß
geschwächt sehen dass sie so etwas wie
den einmarsch in die ukraine nicht mehr
machen können und wir wollen dass sie
ihre militärischen fähigkeiten nicht so
schnell wieder aufbauen können
druck auch aus london berichtet der
guardian
premier boris johnson habe im april vor
seinem kurzbesuch in kiew wurde mir
selensky aufgefordert putin keine
konzessionen zu machen
den gegner schwächen keine kompromisse
machen bei olaf scholz hört sich das
etwas anders an
deshalb ist unser ziel dass putin den
krieg nicht gewinnt wir haben nicht
viele die weit darüber hinausgehen das
muss man dazu sagen das wäre angesichts
der tatsache dass es sich dabei um eine
nuklearmacht handelt eine ganz falsche
zielsetzung
im märz war ukraine präsident selensky
noch kompromissbereit wollte über die
krim und den don bass verhandeln aber
nach militärischen erfolgen und den
verbrechen von butscher formuliert er
jetzt neue ziele
der krieg wird für die ukraine enden
wenn wir bekommen was uns gehört was wir
wollen ist dass wir unser land
zurückbekommen weil es teil unserer
geschichte ist und weil es dem
völkerrecht entspricht
damit sind wir mitten im thema bei uns
ist josef ressel militärexperte der
gasse die russische armee aus der ganzen
ukraine vertreiben donners und krim
zurückholen das ist ein legitimes
kriegsziel aber ist es auch realistisch
also es kommt sehr darauf an in welcher
zeithorizont man legt und wie sich das
personalproblem der russischen armee
jetzt weiterentwickelt im grunde ist es
möglich es ist aber noch sehr weit weg
also die russische armee setzte ihre
offensive im haus derzeit noch fort und
so wird wahrscheinlich bis in den sommer
hinein noch angreifen können dann ist
sie wenn keine mobilmachung erfolgt wenn
kein keine erklärung von einem eines
formellen krieges erfolgt keine
wehrpflichtigen den krieg geschickt
werden dann ist es soweit geschwächt
dass sie nur mehr defensiv agieren kann
weitere personal not könnte sie im
september oktober bekommen wenn weitere
vertrag soldaten wieder ausscheiden
und dann stünde natürlich die
ukrainische armee wächst an weil sie
freiwilligen bekommt die freiwilligen
die kann man nicht sofort in den krieg
schicken die müssen einmal trainiert
werden wir müssen in verbände
zusammengefasst werden diese verbände
müssen wiederum trainiert werden bis sie
taktisch einsatzfähig sind all das
dauert zeit das geht alles in die monate
hinein aber stück für stück wird die
ukrainische armee größer deshalb es gibt
diese schnittmenge etwa im sommer
wo die ukrainische armee wenn sich auf
der russischen seite nichts tut
überhand gewinnen könnte wenn sie die
ausrüstung kriegt und wie gesagt wenn in
moskau keine entscheidungen fallen das
heißt die ukraine muss den krieg
gewinnen hat tatsächlich auch eine
realistische komponente sie kann
durchaus diesen krieg gewinnen die
kranken trick gewinnen dann weiß
natürlich also zb ein wiederherstellen
der waffenstillstandslinie vor dem 24
februar ein einfaches ziel ist als zum
beispiel die krim zurückerobern weil es
gibt zwei straßen und als marke linien
die auf die krim führen das sind relativ
schmale streifen die kann man gut
verteidigen auch die die die frontlinie
die alte kontakt liegen jetzt auf beiden
seiten sehr gut aufgebaut auf der
russischen seite und auf der
ukrainischen seite das erhält die
kontakte nie in gewissen teilen ja auch
ukrainischer seite immer noch weil sie
gut verteidigt bei ist es natürlich wenn
die ukraine die überschreiten wollen
haben sie dasselbe problem wie die
russen hier jeder größe zu bestreiten
suchen das sind gut ausgebaute stellung
system überschreiten gehen also dann
kommen wir in die frage
wie viel verluste will oder kann sie
lenski verkraften und villa in kauf
nehmen das ist dann ein spiel das wird
man wird er auch dann beurteilen wenn es
soweit ist ich glaube viele diskussionen
die jetzt laufen die greifen einfach
noch noch zu weiter aus wir haben noch
sehr viel krieg vor uns leider hab ich
wir haben noch viel krieg falls sekunden
handy sie wir sind ganze frage glauben
sie werden dass russland irgendwann die
mobilmachung macht und einen krieg
ausdruck mir würde das immer als die
mögliche steigerung geschildert
glauben sie dass intensiv dass er fern
ein es hat für putin fiel in ein
politisches risiko wenn das macht es
kann sein es muss nicht sein
er hängt viel von innerrussischen
überlegen und ab in die wir einfach zu
wenig sehen können wir werden sehen wenn
es soweit ist oder wenn es nicht so weit
ist muss ich auch ganz ehrlich sagen wir
wir sind nicht allwissend und dann hat
herr gysi schon eine frage gestellt ich
stelle in die nächste frage marie agnes
strack zimmermann
wir haben heute den bundeskanzler zu
hören können er hat nicht gesagt dass
wir auf jeden fall der ukraine dabei
helfen wollen dass sie diesen krieg
gewinnt er hat gesagt die ukraine muss
bestehen muss man muss marie agnes
strack zimmermann diesem bundeskanzler
weiter dabei helfen einen solchen satz
zu sein na ja das ist natürlich viel
semantik was man sagt der kanzler glaube
ich auch noch nicht das wort schwere
waffen in den mund genommen sondern
strich von schwerem material aber ich
glaube wir sollten uns nicht daran
aufhängen entscheiden was er gesagt hat
ist dass er so lange an der seite der
ukraine solange sie im kampf ist und
wenn man sagt sie muss bestehen bleiben
dann sind das die grenzen von denen wir
jetzt nach der annexion der krim
sprechen nämlich dass er davon ausgeht
und das teilen wir dass die integrierte
grenzen wieder hergestellt wird wir sind
bei einer nächsten formulierung russland
soll nie wieder einen nachbarn
überfallen können das hat der
amerikanische verteidigungsminister
leuten gesagt das sagen übrigens auch
sie russland soll so geschwächt werden
dass es seine nachbarn nie wieder
angreifen kann warum sagt einen solchen
satz der bundeskanzler nicht müsste das
nicht auch sein ziel sein ich bitte
darum unverständnis vielleicht schon ein
dass der kanzler ihnen das vielleicht
sagen würde ich glaube das ist
vielleicht meine mentalität sache die
man was ausdrücklich nicht das ist wenn
sie mich fragen ich persönlich bin der
meinung dass man sie offen darüber
sprechen muss weil
russland zu sagen ihr müsst in eine
situation kommen dass er nie wieder auf
die idee kommt so ein schritt zu gehen
nämlich ein land zu überfallen sind ja
mehrere komponenten das militärische ja
es muss dann natürlich ein riesiges land
und wenn es zwei tat eine armee wieder
aufzubauen würde es das militärisch
können aber es ist die frage die
wirtschaftliche frage russland ist
wirtschaftlich schwer angeschlagen
aufgrund der immer größeren druck der
ausgeübt wird auf russland und es ist
auch eine frage des willens ich glaube
es war moltke der mal gesagt hat dass
ein sieg bedeutet nicht nur militärisch
sondern sozusagen den willen des anderen
zu brechen anzugreifen und da wird
natürlich die frage sein wer kommt nach
putin
wie lange wird diese gesellschaft auch
die russische gesetz stehen noch das
noch hinnehmen denn wenn sie noch ein
wort erlauben es ist bekannt dass
umgekehrt ungefähr das ist kein
geheimnis über 20.000 russen gefallen
sind überwiegend aus den
zentralasiatischen staaten er hat aber
schon angekündigt seinen leuten das
opfer zu bringen sind das heißt jetzt
kommen auch die ersten serie zurück der
moskauer jungen leute derer in sankt
petersburg erschwert also die
gesellschaft darauf ein und das bedeutet
dass er sich auf etwas längeres
einstellt dass ihm aber auch klar sein
muss dass unter umständen auch einen
gewissen widerstand erzeugt werden kann
wenn 18 19 jährigen krieg gezogen werden
und nicht mehr nach hause so und jetzt
ist so interessant dass ich eigentlich
eine frage nach der deutschen politik
gestellt hatte war zu dem was sich da in
russland und in der ukraine tut kommen
wir auf jeden fall noch wir sind bei
dieser bundesregierung und freuen uns
über markus feldenkirchen der uns heute
in dieser sendung toller weise wieder
mit der einen oder anderen guten these
zur verfügung stehen wird kann ein
bundeskanzler schon deshalb nicht so
viel klartext sprechen wie frau
strack-zimmermann weil er sich
politische spielräume halten muss oder
glauben sie das sind wirklich
kommunikative
ungeschicklichkeiten das sind große
kommunikative defizite und ich beobachte
dass er wirklich seit wochen von der
seitenlinie wie frau statt zimmermann
sich dann immer wieder darum bemüht auch
das was sie und dem bundeskanzler
verbindet zu betonen manchmal gelegt
dass auch nicht dann redet sie auch
klartext aber das bemühen ist da und ich
glaube auch das haben wir gerade gehört
wieder dieses bemühen ich glaube dass es
nicht nur unterschiedliche mentalitäten
sind da wollen zwei politische kräfte
schon was anderes vorstadt zimmermann
möchte sowohl symbolisch als auch was
die faktische unterstützung mit waffen
auch schweren waffen angeht weitaus mehr
als das was der bundeskanzler bilder
bundeskanzler wird von woche zu woche
quasi ein meter mehr gedrängt von leuten
die eine position mit frau zimmermann
haben sind natürlich auch noch andere
auch in der bundesregierung und so
bewegt er sich langsam zaudernd macht
dann semantische kniffe sagt es werden
schwere waffen geliefert wird
wahrscheinlich noch drüber sprechen die
frage ist dann ob wirklich viele schwere
waffen geliefert werden da gibt es auch
ganz andere berichte darüber also da
gibt es schon ein wirklich
unterschiedliche motive und
unterschiedliche richtung nach dem
politischen spielraum hat sich gefragt
wir sind toller weise verbunden heute
abend mit jewgenia bello sitz in kiew
autoren und fotografen frau bella rosa
an den guten abend zu ihnen sie waren
bis letzte woche noch in berlin
und ich frage sie unbedingt noch
natürlich danach welchen eindruck sie
jetzt von kiel farben aber welchen
hatten sie mitgenommen hier aus
deutschland diese diskussion um die
briefeschreiber um die klarheit und
präzision des deutschen kanzlers
diese diskussion war für mich
schmerzhaft und enttäuschend aber
gleichzeitig die stimmung in deutschland
war sehr inspirierend ich spürte die
unterstützung und die solidarität der
menschen
seitdem sei der ersten minute als ich
nach berlin gekommen war aus gier und
ich habe damals verstanden dass es für
mich leicht sein wird in berlin zu sein
auch noch meinen kriegs langen
kriegserfahrungen deswegen es war auch
irgendwie erträglich diese diskussionen
mit zu verfolgen
ja und herr gysi hat schon eine frage
gestellt war also schon dran deshalb
kommt die nächste frage gleich wieder zu
ihnen vorher gucken wir uns nämlich an
wie sehr unser gast frau
strack-zimmermann den bundeskanzler in
den letzten wochen zum jagen getragen
hat
wochenlang stand olaf scholz wegen
ausbleibender panzerlieferungen in der
kritik auch aus den eigenen reihen ich
weiß nicht warum der kanzler probleme
hat immer ein wort das ihr panzer in den
mund zu nehmen oder schwere waffen
versteh's nicht vergangene woche der
eklat fdp abgeordnete verließen aus
protest gegen scholz den
verteidigungsausschuss
leider wurden sehr viele fragen noch
nicht beantwortet
deswegen haben wir als freie demokraten
um kurz nach 9 entschieden dass wir die
sitzung jetzt verlassen die
ausschussvorsitzende wickelte hinterher
ab und dankte dem kanzler marcus faber
dagegen trat als verteidigungspolitische
fdp sprecher zurück dabei war es marie
agnes strack zimmermann die den
bundeskanzler immer wieder vor sich her
trieb wir haben zu führen nicht nur
wirtschaftlich sondern auch militärisch
und für die die diese rolle nicht
annehmen wollen sage ich dann sitzen sie
wo möglicherweise im falschen moment am
falschen platz meine forderung ist
erstmal und mein wunsch dass der
bundeskanzler sich jetzt mal dafür
ausspricht dass wir grundsätzlich
schwere waffen liefern artillerie
möglicherweise panzer das problem ist
das zögern zaudern das nicht mutig sein
das nervt die leute
jetzt ist kann man glaube ich nicht mehr
sagen das system an tig ist hier ist die
frage
ukrainische botschafter melnik heute die
deutschen haben immer noch nicht die
schweren waffen geliefert würden sie in
anbetracht dessen sagen
immer noch sagen dass der bundeskanzler
ein bremser ist
wo das sind ja zwei interessante fragen
die sie mir stellen erst mal wenig der
zu beginn des krieges sehr stark über
die medien kommuniziert hat ich erinnere
mich an einen augenblick der
kommunikativ schwierig war sie
ministerin von 5.000 hemmen sprach das
war ungeschickt aber gleichzeitig
wenigen einer sendung gesagt hat dass
sie 100.000 wollen also es ging dann so
war völlig irre was dafür zahlen durch
den raum gegen das heißt es wurde
relativ viel übrigens auch als wir uns
mit herrn merkmal bei ihnen getroffen
haben hat er gesagt er will dass und
jetzt will das doch nichts sie sprechen
von dem gp hat da hatte er das ist alles
aufgezeichnet worden sagt jetzt wollen
wir doch nicht weil es keine munition
gibt also sie wollen sagen herr wenig
widerspricht sich auch dann und wann ja
er sucht die öffentlichkeit um druck zu
machen das ist ein bild das recht für
sie verstehe ja ich will ihnen das nur
erklären aber der song trunk auf diesen
bunten lassen nämlich dass nur zu ende
weil das ist schon relevant ist es hat
keinen sinn über die medien wünsche zu
erfüllen man muss schon oder bitte darum
zu bitten man muss schon sagen man muss
offiziell darum bitten so da gibt es
eine note erreicht man ein wir sind ja
nicht auf dem basar das ist das eine ich
persönlich habe eine andere mentalität
und auch auf den ausschnitt denen sie
gerade gezeigt haben ich habe den
kanzler eingeladen das übrigens nichts
unanständiges
denn die sind parlamentarierinnen und
parlamentarier und wir kontrollieren als
legislative die exekutive und damit das
kabinett und ich habe auch frau baerbock
eingeladen die gekommen ist ich hab die
innenministerin eingeladen die hatte aus
zwei tieren nicht alle aufzählen frauen
ja das ist schauen wie war das ja sie
haben dass sie also ein bisschen als
skandal ihn gestellt und er war ein
kollege von mir der fühlte sich nicht
der fühlte sich nicht informiert ich
persönlich meine fragen wurden
beantwortet seine nicht ob man dann früh
aufsteht und geht das mag ich mal ab
unter fragen wie man sich benimmt mir ja
das lassen wir jetzt mal so ich wünsch
ich dir ich den kanzler handfester
wünschen sie sich den kanzler klarer
wünschen wir sind bei dem was sie sagen
ja ist immer noch eine sauna in der
kanzler- ich finde sie haben das ganz
gut beschrieben dass er sich jetzt schon
an das artikuliert also da ist bewegung
schauen sie die reden von einer
zeitenwende geht es nicht nur um geld
für die bundeswehr da geht es auch darum
da kann man unterschiedlicher meinung
sein dass die menschen erkennen dass ein
krieg in der ukraine vor unserer haustür
der macht was mit uns da geht es um
unsere freiheitlichen werte und ich
glaube dass es hilfreich ist dem ein
oder anderen dinge zu erklären dass da
gerade passiert und ich glaube einfache
und deutliche sprache fallen einigen
ohnmacht und sagen oh gott was kommt da
andere sagen jetzt habe ich es
verstanden das ist einfach hebt in der
situation die bundesregierung kommt
natürlich von einem zumindest
sozialdemokratische teil der
bundesregierung von einem ganz anderen
blatt o also als der krieg losging habe
ich mit mitgliedern der bundesregierung
gesprochen die mir erzählt eigentlich
sei es schon unethisch wenn die ukraine
da jetzt zur großen verteidigung
ansetzen würde weil es gibt ja keine
chance und dann soll man auch dass das
töten in kriegshandlungen doch am besten
umgeht es war aber nicht nur in dieser
zeitung natürlich aber wenn das der
ausgangspunkt war hat dann hat sich der
bundeskanzler natürlich enorm bewegen
aber halt immer nur getrieben und
zaghaft und letztlich will er auch immer
noch quasi den eindruck erwecken als
hätte sich nicht so ganz bewegt ansatz
gibt es da auch noch eine rede über die
spielräume gregor gysi bekommt diese
frage sie haben sich explizit
ausgesprochen gegen waffenlieferungen
herr gießen aus deutschland sie waren
wie frau strack zimmermann in der
ukraine und auch einige tage frau strack
zimmermann plädiert vehement dafür weil
sie sagt nur so ist der krieg zu stoppen
andere in diesem grund auch sie sagen
nein warum nein
und ich das kurz erklären wenn sie den
kanzler verstehen ein kanzler muss
anders auftreten als die vorsitzende des
verteidigungsausschusses er trägt ja
eine andere form von verantwortung aber
richtig ist dass er getrieben wurde das
eher getrieben wurde und dann immer
wieder ein stück nachgegeben das stimmt
völlig was sie da erzählt haben lassen
sie es mich ganz kurz erklären ich bin
1948 geboren worden ich habe als kind
und später noch richtig die folgen des
schlimmsten krieges der
menschheitsgeschichte des zweiten
weltkrieges erlebt mit 50 millionen
toten der von deutschland ausging und
deshalb ist für mich der beschluss
gefasst worden jetzt gleich ganz kurz
erläutern dass deutschland nie wieder
einkriegen gewinn machen soll wir sind
inzwischen der fünftgrößte
waffenexporteur der welt das heißt egal
ob ein krieg in libyen stattfindet in
syrien im jemen in mali oder die türkei
völkerrechtswidrig einmarschiert im irak
wir verdienen immer daran das gefällt
mir nicht und wenn wir jetzt warten alle
ja moment wenn wir jetzt waffen an die
ukraine liefern die beiden deutschen
konzerne die die herstellen bekommen
zudem sei sieben und anbieter sie werden
nicht bezahlt die geschenken das habe
ich nicht gehört das bezahlt die
bundesregierung und wieder machen bei
uns gewinne am krieg und deshalb sage
ich immer andere länder haben eine
andere geschichte verstehen sie die
können auch waffen liefern
ich finde wenn wir das gleiche geld wie
andere länder ausgeben für ein
humanitäres sie sind wenn wir das so
aber die anderen sollen helfen nur wir
nicht ja wir haben einmal andere
geschichte als 100 ländern das ist der
punkt und die anderen ländern können das
gerne machen und es gibt zwei dinge nur
die hier diskutiert wurde die ich finde
dass wir uns nicht zu stehen ich mag
nicht die leute die mir schreiben die
ukraine soll bedingungslos kapitulieren
ich finde das geht uns nichts an das hat
die ukrainische führung möglichst in
übereinstimmung mit ihrer bevölkerung zu
entscheiden ich finde aber auch der
einsatz von feuerwehr bock falsch der
krieg ist zu ende wenn der letzte
russische soldat die ukraine
verlassenheit sondern wenn die ukraine
und die russische führung sich
irgendwann auf etwas verständigen was
zum waffenstillstand führt egal ob was
haben wir das zu akzeptieren
nicht wir dürfen von außen der
ukrainischen regierung vorschreiben was
sie zu tun hat und was sie nicht tun
darf und da das ist schade ich ehrlich
gesagt ja kein natürlich wenn sie sagen
erst wenn der letzte russische soldat
und die grenzen ich hoffe ja dass es
doch wieder eine vermittlung gibt die
neutralen staaten die früher vermittelt
haben machen das ja von ihrer auffassung
und fragen aber ich ein gräser meiner
auffassung gesagt zur geschichte und
wissen ich kriegen jahrgang 48 sie sind
jünger deshalb dürfen sie dazu auch
andere auffassungen haben aber meine
auffassung ist durch meine zeit geprägt
nur das foto so wie sie sollen das auch
unbedingt sagen und wir denken noch mal
eine sekunde darüber nach umfragen unser
gräßel ist diese vorwurf eigentlich
berechtigt dass die deutschen insgesamt
im verbund der nato und alle
unterstützenden länder
so wenig leisten ist das richtig die
zeit hat mal ordentlich nachgezählt und
sagt wir sind im guten mittelfeld
deutschland ist im mittelfeld
diddy diddy sache ist natürlich die an
wen wird deutschland gemessen also
deutschland ist ein werk das größte
jetzt land innerhalb der europäischen
union sie ist unter den europäischen
nato alliierten nach frankreich und
großbritannien einer der
wichtigsten rüstungs zentren
technologisch führend die bundeswehr ist
jetzt auch nicht 1 1 eine armee die auf
der nudelsuppe daher spielt auch wenn
natürlich viel federn hat lassen müssen
in dem sinn ist jetzt die
erwartungshaltung an deutschland
natürlich in dieser krise die ja eine
krise der europäischen sicherheit ist
die ist ja nicht nur der ukraine ihr
privat problem eine andere als an
bulgarien oder an estland und dieser
diese rolle vor allen dingen auch vor
dem vor dem immer gehegten anspruch vor
allen dingen unter den tramp jahren dass
man ja für die eigene sicherheit des
europäischen kontinents mehr tun will
und das die eigenverantwortung der
europäer etc vor dem hintergrund dieser
rhetorik natürlich schon gar nicht
und das zweite und da kommen natürlich
auch bei der schlechten kommunikation
rein
das was man macht hat man dann zum teil
auch wirklich entweder unter dem
schimmel gekehrt
oder man hat einfach viele dinge im
unklaren lage wirklich im unklaren
gelassen wo man wirklich steht
die ganze herum eierei um die definition
schwerer waffen die hätte man sich von a
bis z schenken können sondern man hat
von vornherein sagen können wir liefern
das was jetzt im zuge der sozusagen der
ausbildungs technischen und der
logistischen vorbereitung im in der
gegenwärtigen phase des konflikts in
macht und man mit der ukrainischen armee
auch sinnvoll abwickeln kann ob das
jetzt das war eine anfangszeit natürlich
noch nicht gewusst hat wie schnell die
russischen kräfte vorständen dann
natürlich eher leichte waffen weil man
auch in einen guerillakrieg verwenden
kann aber so wie sich der krieg ändert
ändern sich die bedürfnisse also da hat
man einfach viele viele diskussionen
gespannen die sonst auch nicht
diskutiert in anderen ländern auch nicht
diskutiert werden da wird da wird nicht
jeder stein und 50.000 mal umgedreht und
heute inneren sinn gesucht wird gemeldet
dass darüber haben wir hier natürlich
auch schon viel gesprochen ob und wie
sehr man die vermutung haben konnte dass
man nicht liefern will und zwischendurch
die vermutung haben musste dass man
liefern will aber nicht liefern kann und
das sind natürlich verschiedene dinge
heute wird gemeldet dass sich der
niederländische premier und olaf scholz
auf 12 panzerhaubitzen verständigt hätte
wir reden über zwölf die ein
nennenswerter beitrag sind weil sie
verglichen zu den anderen wirklich
helfen herr grassl helfen sie uns da
noch mit einer kurzen einschätzung ist
jede hobby zu ist wichtig das problem
dass die ukraine da hat sie verschießt
normalerweise in dieser in dieser klasse
das kaliber 152 mm das sozusagen das
russische mittlere artillerie kaliber
das wird in der nato nicht fast nicht
mehr produziert es gibt in tschechien
eine firma die stelle in einer woche ein
paar 100 granaten her die ukrainische
verschießt glaube ich noch 1000 pro tag
oder so was ist also da geht wirklich
mission weiter das nato kaliber als ein
anderer die ukrainische munitionsfabrik
sind mittlerweile zerstört die das
während des ganzen sommers krieges im
eigenen saft
wenn sie unsere munition verwenden will
braucht sie auch geschützte aus denen
schießen kann wir können nicht nato und
in den garten stellen die sie nicht
verkehrt einschießen folgendes gesagt
die modernsten waffen können schon
deshalb nicht geliefert werden weil die
russen die ja auch zum teil erobern und
dann alle geheimnisse kennen also das
fand ich aber interessant über marken
von den amerikanern wir sind bevor wir
nochmal über die ziele des westens reden
die verschiedenen ziele ganz kurz aufbau
lamprecht nochmal feldenkirchen herr
merz hat heute dazu aufgefordert dass
diese verteidigungsministerin gehen muss
in ihren augen zu recht
märz gesagt da muss man es vielleicht
mit vorsicht genießen allerdings es ist
schon tragisch das in einer phase wo das
verteidigungsministerium die größte
bedeutung seit gründung der
bundesrepublik überhaupt hat dort jemand
sitzt der sich vorher mit bundeswehr und
verteidigungspolitik nicht befasst hatte
sicherlich frau lamprecht starten in
anderen bereichen hat auch ein anderes
ministerium gut geführt hat er aber
weder vorkenntnisse hat noch den
aus sicht der militärs kollegen haben
recherchiert auch in reihen der
bundeswehr den nötigen elan mitbringt
sich das darauf zu ziehen was man in
dieser position
haben muss und so wirkt sie aus sicht
vieler in der bundeswehr aber auch
anderer politischer beobachter doch ein
bisschen auf verlorenem posten dieser
tag vor merz heute mit der forderung
dass frau lamprecht zurücktritt frau
strack-zimmermann was sagt da die
spezialistin für verteidigung
naja märz hat ja ist ja das opfer von
frau merkel vor 16 jahren geworden er
wurde er von ihr über nacht kalt
gestellt ich glaube da ist auch spielt
ja auch ein großes trauma eine rolle ich
fand dass in diesem kontext völlig
daneben das war unsachlich ist war auch
schlichtweg unhöflich und
lambrecht eine gute
verteidigungsminister ich erlebe sie als
gute verteidigungsministerin das war sie
gerade gesagt haben in einer solchen
situation jemanden zu haben der vom
militär versteht da kann ich nur sagen
sie muss entscheidungen treffen ja nein
letztlich auch im kabinett aber sie hat
militär um sich herum sie hat ein
generalinspekteur
sie haben sechs inspekteure sie hat sehr
viel nur um sich herum und da muss eine
beratung erfolgen das würde übrigens
auch jemand machen und der mann paar
monate dienst geschoben hat und gesagt
hat ich habe gedient ich bin nur richtig
traf also es muss man jetzt auch mal ein
bisschen relativieren nicht jeder der
bei der bundeswehr war ist hier der
große feldherr also sie hat ein
entsprechende
fach expertise um sich herum und musste
das letzte essen wollen und dann ich
kann nur sagen herum und muss dann ja
oder nein sagen beziehungsweise auch im
kabinett das rüberbringen und sie ist
eine sehr loyale ministerin ihrem
kanzler gegenüber ihrem kanzler
gegenüber das ist auch ein satz den
lassen wir uns noch mal auf der zunge
zergehen und sie beantworten wir
trotzdem noch die frage ist in ihren
augen eine gute verteidigungsminister
also ich hab die vorgängerin erlebt die
unter ganz anderen vorbedingungen
gearbeitet hat und ich behaupte dass
ihre vorgängerin nicht besser gewesen
wäre angesichts der situation es gibt
keine verteidigungsminister ministerin
in der bundeswehr die erlebt hat nach 80
tagen im amt losgelöst ob sie weiß was
sache ist die einem solchen thema
konfrontiert wurde und also
sozialdemokratie kommt wo eine völlig
andere diskussionskultur ist werden eine
große kollegen sie haben ja die spd auf
eine menge dinge da wurde sehr lange
diskutiert und nun steht sie mitten mit
den stiefeln
in den songs aber die sich die
beweggründe warum jemand dieses wichtige
amt bekommt müssen schon noch mal
überdacht werden aber ist kramp
karrenbauer war das weil sie in einem
innerparteilichen machtkampf jens spahn
nicht dieses amt überlassen wollte die
beweggründe von herrn scholz sich für
frau lamprecht zu entscheiden sind bis
heute auch noch nicht klar kommuniziert
also ich finde da sollten zumindest in
der zukunft andere standards mit der
unfallstelle ist dass ich ihnen jetzt
naja sind und dennoch sind sie hier eben
auch in dieser regierung und in dieser
ampelfrau stark zimmermann hier aber wie
ich möchte eine nachricht also an dieser
frau sich abgearbeitet wird und wenn wir
jetzt mal losgelöst von ihrem einwurf
jetzt mal schauen über was reden wir
seit wochen dass die fingernägel
lackiert hat haben sie auch dass sie
hohe schuhe trägt dass sie dass sie die
haare wild hat
aber das gehört zur wahrheit dazu dass
das an der stelle aufgegangen wird und
wenn sie bei 20 grad - aus einem panzer
steigen der spiegelglatt ist und ein
soldat reicht in die hand da ist das
nicht dämlich und ist es sehr hilfreich
was ich nur sagen will objektiv objektiv
gibt es keinen grund warum frau
lamprecht heute zurückziehen sollte
außer dass über nebensächlichkeiten
diskutiert wird und deswegen fand ich
das heute von herrn merz der amiwiese
und da verweisen jedoch heute angefangen
hat unternehmen besser abzuarbeiten
haben der große staatsmann in sondern
haben wir darüber genug geredet herr
gysi wir sind noch mal bei der frage wie
einig ist der westen in bezug auf die
ziele in diesem krieg ja wissen jetzt ps
und damit er an ob wir uns nur über
waffen verständigen oder auch über
andere hilfe ich war ja mit professor
doktor trabert mehrere tage dort in mit
in butter in prien in kiew
grad heißt das glaube ich an einem
vorort wir haben mit dem bürgermeister
wir haben armenküchen besucht wir haben
die krankenhäuser besucht werden
medizinische geräte überreicht wir haben
medikamente überreicht und vor allen
dingen haben wir spenden überreicht
26.000 euro hatten wir mit damit sich
auch sehr gefreut und immer gefragt was
sie dringend benötigen und er leitet
eine ein verein der heißt armut und
gesundheit und darüber organisieren wir
jetzt spenden um den krankenhäusern und
in anderen einrichtungen das zu schicken
was sie dringend benötigen ich habe mich
auch ein bundesminister habeck gewarnt
welche geräte diese vorstadt dringend
benötigt wir diskutieren hier in
deutschland seit wochen nur über packen
es gibt doch auch humanitäre hegeler
ungeheuer wie sich lange reden auch über
wirtschaftliche hilfe und wir reden über
die aufnahme der flüchtlinge in diesem
land und wie man vor ort jetzt haben sie
es selber erwähnt herr gysi und dann
muss ich noch mal sehr sie hilfe für
flüchtlinge ich bin boes gegen
hersteller erster zweiter und dritter
klasse möglichst nur flüchtlinge erster
klasse ich wollte gerne noch mal darauf
aufmerksam machen dass sie aus butter
sich mit einem besonderen suite meldeten
ich hätte das jetzt nicht thematisiert
wenn sie darüber nicht gerade
höchstselbst gesprochen hätte und der
hat für einige verwunderung gesorgt hier
zum abschluss waren wir in butter ich
bin sehr für die internationale
untersuchung zu den kriegsverbrechen die
hier stattgefunden haben sollen damit
wir hoffentlich erfahren was hier
tatsächlich passierte
ganz so war nicht unglücklich
ausgedrückt aber es liegt daran dass
sich rechtsanwalt bin bis zur
rechtskräftigen verurteilung gilt immer
jemand als schuldig dass selbst beim
leben kriegsverbrecherprozess nürnberg
deshalb formuliert die acht wählte immer
so aber ich bin davon überzeugt dass das
kriegsverbrechen gab aber wir haben ja
experten hingeschickt die das jetzt
aufklären sollen und bald wenn wir die
ergebnisse und ich bin sehr für die
verfolgung von kriegsverbrechern
allerdings aller kriegsverbrecher der
usa ausgeben zweifel sollte man nicht
den krieg im irak der muss noch
krieg ausgerechnet in diesen zwei mal
verstehen sie solange es keine
rechtskräftige verurteilung gibt
irgendjemand als unschuldig das ist in
einem anwalt so verbringt sie da gab es
sich sagen
können ich habe gar keinen zweifel dass
das so kriegsverbrechen
jetzt müssen wir die ergebnisse der
experten abwarten und von den
ergebnissen werden wir dann glaube ich
alle ausgehen ich habe da keine zweifel
dass die vorstellung die die treffen
dann auch die grundlage sind auch
übrigens einer notwendigen
strafrechtlichen verfolgung aber nochmal
wenn die kriegsverbrechen weingarten
potter herr größe die sind endlich bei
der frage apropos butscher und mario
pohl der
präsident der ukraine hat seine ziele
anders formuliert noch vor istanbul hat
er sich verhandlungsbereit erzählt
gezeigt und wäre sogar über minsk in
ausgegangen über münster hinaus gegangen
weil er auch über die krim und die
gesamten zwei orders verhandeln wollte
also dann jetzt und lohans und jetzt
formuliert er dass er die russen raus
haben möchte aus der ukraine sehen sie
einen unterschied zwischen dem was der
ukrainische präsident auch sein
außenminister die amerikaner und die
briten sagen und dem wie die
europäischen die westeuropäischen
staatschefs formulieren also london
london und washington bis berlin und ich
glaube viele viele ziele decken sich
viele sg hat sich verhärtet ja
allerdings war also über die creme eine
art leasing und buy.com lugansk nur über
die territorien innerhalb der kontakt
kennen das war am anfang so hat aber
auch gesehen dass die russin überhaupt
nicht bereit sind darüber zu reden und
das überhaupt keine
willen auch darüber besteht hier
entgegenkommen zu
einzugehen indem sie die gespräche
gingen dann ab woche zwei nur mehr um
gefangenenaustausch um humanitäre
korridore aus belagerten städten da war
null substanz einer einer einer
weitreichenden politischen lösung der
hintergrund gingen die lange nicht und
deshalb ist es auch kein wunder dass sie
dass die gespräch jetzt nicht da sind
die der innenpolitische druck natürlich
ist noch mal erhöht nach deutschland
nach mario pohl nach all dem was jetzt
ans tageslicht gekommen ist und was auch
jetzt den den den gefangenen aus mario
pohl jetzt blüht das würde auch noch mal
eine erinnerung der ukrainischen
öffentlichkeit sein dass man einen ein
abkommen oder einem handschlag oder ein
tauschgeschäft mit russland ja nicht
dass man ihm nicht vertrauen darf weil
es war ja an und für sich einen
gefangenenaustausch vorgesehen diese
verwundeten soldaten und jetzt werden
sie in
nach russland verschleppt und dort
inhaftiert also eigentlich in einem
schauprozess nun wahrscheinlich einem
schauprozess zugeführt wahrscheinlich
unter folter geständnisse
herausgequetscht also dass das muss man
noch mal dazu sehen das ist ein date der
krieg entwickelt sich sie sehen keine so
großen unterschiede sie sagen es sind
nuancen es sind man es sind nun auch die
schwäche russlands natürlich wenn die
russische armee wenn die russischer
medien krieg so verliert wie sie wie
sind jetzt angefangen hat zu verlieren
und dann dann sozusagen aus diesem krieg
geschwächt raus geht dann ist sie nicht
in der lage deshalb für schweden und
finnland gehen hat deshalb jetzt in die
nato weil die russische armee schon
keinen zweiten großen krieg in europa
mehr aufreißen wir haben die die truppen
dafür gibt es nicht weder wird ein
historischer fenster genutzt und und
hier wird ein fenster genutzt auf immer
ich weiß nicht wo diese die dieses wort
herkommt ist natürlich eine sehr harte
formulierung war gibt es gar nichts aber
zumindest für die nächsten jahre wenn
nicht jahrzehnte ist die russische armee
jetzt mal auch wirklich substanziell
geschwächt sind endlich wieder in kiel
frau belarus 7 müssen uns entschuldigen
dass wir diese runde in der deutschen
innen außenpolitik noch drehen mussten
wie groß ist ihre sorge dass dieser
krieg ein langer krieg werden wird und
dass die hilfe die unterstützung abnimmt
haben sie die sorge im angesicht dessen
was heute aus washington und london zu
hören war oder haben sie diese sorge
nicht
ich bekomme wieder diese sorge wenn ich
herrn gysi zuhörer und höhere über die
humanitäre hilfe anstalten schweren
waffen und wenn es geht darum jetzt dass
mein land
zerstört wird ich war gerade vor kurzem
in butter in der gegend von butscher war
in einem kleinen dorf das heißt es ist
es liegt nahe an butscher 80 prozent der
häuser sind zerstört
kulturzentrum total zerstört alle leben
im dorf zerstört den toren ist
geschrieben hier sind kinder und
menschen die hinter diesen toren
zerstört wenn ich das sehe geräten das
erinnert mich sofort an taten
neben diesen taten wie sie wissen gab es
diese zwei riesige worte kinder und wir
wissen dass dieses theater
gezielt bombardiert war und in dieser
situation wo mein land schritt für
schritt durch eine absolut zynisch
aggressive card zerstört wird über die
humanitäre hilfe zu sprechen es ist
eigentlich zu zu sagen ja diese
zerstörungen sind okay für uns wir
können das einfach ansehen wir gewöhnen
uns langsam an diese schlechten
nachrichten aus diesem gebet wir lassen
es zu dass die menschen sterben täglich
aber wir werden ein paar arznei bringen
für die leidenden und die wirtschaft
mann des landes entschuldigung ist auch
gerade zugrunde zerstörten die menschen
wollen zurückkehren als ich nach wie vor
vor mit mir eine frau den 18i gibt
zurückkehrte und sie war hoffnungsvoll
sie hat gesagt mein gott wie glücklich
ich bin hause zu kommen mit der ersten
erlauben ist habe ich sofort hinzu
genommen und kehre zurück aber ich weiß
es wartet keine arbeit auf mich und ich
werde sehr stadt kämpfen müssen um in
meiner stadt zu überleben also
wollen wir hätten die sie einmal
antworten lassen herr gysi es ist so
verrückt weil sie haben ihre eigene
parteispitze ehemalige muss man sagen
sagt sahra wagenknecht und kollegen
selber in einem brief beziehen und haben
sich darüber geklagt wie vollständig
emotionslos ihre parteifreunde da sind
und waren das stück ist ihnen
offensichtlich jede empathie fehlt für
das was da zerstört wird ja aber bei mir
nicht ich war ja mehrere tage dort und
das hat mich sehr mitgenommen ich habe
mir die zerstörten wohnung angesehen
auch die zerstörten panzer in die
zerstörten autos ich habe mir das ja
alles unmittelbar an gesehen ich war
stundenlang auch in zügen unterwegs
insofern meine empathie ist ganz groß an
alle lehrer habe ich ja gesagt können
auch waffen liefern wegen das
selbstverteidigungsrecht der ukraine
deutschland aufgrund seiner geschichte
nach meinen erfahrungen nicht
stattdessen deutschland humanitäre hilfe
ich sag doch nicht dass sie keine waffen
bekommt gehört wusste ich sage ja nicht
von deutschland aber ich habe schon
gesagt das ist meine prägung ich bin
1948 geboren worden und habe da meine
erfahrung gemacht und sie haben die
lehre ist auch nicht unwichtig wissen
sie wenn sie in den krankenhäusern sind
und die sagt ich habe so viele kranke
und verletzte ich kann das nicht machen
ich kann jenes nicht machen ich kann
dieses nicht mal ich würde das nicht so
herunter drücken als ob das keinen wert
hat also für die wo wir waren hatte das
einen großen wert und die waren auch
dankbar dafür dass sie von uns solche
dinge bekommen haben und wir sammeln
jetzt und schicken weitere dinge hin
also ich sage immer beides muss man
sehen und deutschland hat der geschichte
als andere länder das muss man nur immer
wieder zur kenntnis in welcher dann
frage ich
finde die menschen sind sehr dankbar
flug denke die flehen nach deutschland
sind dankbar für jede kleine hilfe dafür
dass sie weiterleben können wer sie am
leben geblieben sind menschen sind auge
dankbar aber es bedeutet nicht dass man
mit der geschichte rechtfertigen kann
das was heute passiert heute heutige tag
ist auf unsere geschichte unsere
gemeinsame geschichte und wir planen
eine gemeinsame zukunft und über
heutigen tag werden die geschichtsbücher
geschrieben und dieser krieg dann konnte
es nicht geben
2014 hat russland ukraine attackiert
schrecklich zynisch ukraine war
unvorbereitet in der ukraine gab es
keine armee in der ukraine war
unglaublich friedlich ukrainische
gesellschaft hat so gar nicht diskutiert
in kleinsten diskussionen dass man die
creme mit der gewalt zurückerobern kann
russland hat aus meinung friedlichen
land wirklich freundlich und ein mittel
militarisierte 's land gemacht zweiter
vor 2014 70 prozent der ukraine ukraine
waren gegen beitritt in nato sie können
darüber alle sitze elegien nachlesen
jetzt wollen denke mehr als 80 prozent
der ukraine ins na ja aber es weiter und
14 waren auch faschisten in der
regierung zum glück sind die jetzt nicht
mehr im parlament die nicht mehr in der
regierung
doch ganz klar
aber lassen wir das wichtigste mein land
zu mit nach hause elektrisiert
militarisiert
ohne und ja ich wollte darüber reden ich
wollte ich wollte sagen dass mein land
hat sich militarisiert nicht freiwillig
sondern weil wir ab markiert waren weil
wir angegriffen waren und sind und in
dieser situation leider befinden wir uns
immer noch und das bayerische politik
das brand lässt ukrainische zukunft und
deswegen
das konrad 70 ukraine nicht aussuchen
fragen wir nochmal der saat ag sieht das
stimmt fragen wir nochmal nach mario
pohl und den eingeschlossenen kämpfern
in azoff stahl das ist interessant dass
sie erwähnen und es ist auch wichtig für
euch den zuschauern zu erklären diesem
als auch bataillon wurde immer
unterstellt dass es auch nazis und
neonazis in sich hat wie viel davon ist
russische propaganda wie viel ist wahr
und was denken sie dass mit den kämpfern
den soldaten vor ort passiert
das fragen sie mich ja also es ist
wirklich
batterien also
heutzutage gehört zur ukrainischen
armee
offiziellen
abteilungen der ukrainisch und dort gibt
es menschen die unterschiedliche
sprachen sprechen
ich habe vor kurzem
letzte worte wurden zitiert von einem
bekannten oder freunden einen sterbenden
soldaten aus als ob und seine letzte
worte sprach er auf russisch es gibt
dort menschen mit unterschiedlichsten
einsichten aber das wichtigste die
menschen da sind gekommen um ukraine zu
verteidigen heute fuhr ich mit meiner
mutter durch die stadt und dann erfuhr
ist die die nachricht dass person ihres
bekannten freundes ukrainischen lyrikers
selbst auch ein junge lyriker in bayona
soffin mario pahl anscheinend war und
ums leben gekommen ist meine mutter war
erschüttert und und in dieser realität
wo nicht jetzt und was wollte ich sagen
mit meiner früheren
also heute unterstreichen dass seit 2004
10 diesen angriff hat europäische union
auf deutschland wirklich nicht genug
gemacht um den nächsten angriff zu
stoppen
putin hat in dieser zeit ressourcen
gesammelt gerate er hat gelder gesammelt
alles gesammelt und darauf haben wir
reagiert
um diesen krieg zu planen warum redet
jetzt die ganze welt wird jetzt putin
muss gestoppt werden wirklich gestoppt
werden für immer darüber redet in der
nationale politische mädchen darüber
reden ukrainische politiker wir
verstehen wenn wurde nicht gestoppt wird
für immer da passiert eine stille phase
die wir zu lassen in dieser stillen
phase kann nächster angriff vorbereitet
werden wie jetzt schon gerade passierte
für es bedeutet airport noch mehr gefahr
und noch und keine europäische
sicherheit und es wäre nicht zu stoppen
warum spricht dann marie agnes strack
zimmermann
der französische präsident davon dass
man darauf achten müsse putin nicht zu
demütigen das kann ich ihnen nicht
erklären ich halte das die die das thema
demütigen oder er darf sein gesicht
nicht verlieren für überhaupt kein
kriterium für wladimir putin er hat noch
vor einem jahr ein aufsatz geschrieben
dass die ukraine kein recht hat zu
existieren ja das angekündigt übrigens
in der tat war das vorspiel 2014 wo wir
eben nicht wirklich so reagiert haben
wir hätten reagieren sollen zumal in der
zeit in den letzten acht jahren 14.000
menschen in der ost ukraine bereits ums
leben gekommen sind warum der
französische präsident das so sieht mag
innenpolitische gründe haben hab jetzt
noch national wahlen vor sich und will
da vielleicht nicht für unruhe sorgen
aber es ist völlig absurd dass wir
unsere kriterien die wir menschenrechte
akzeptieren freiheit respekt voreinander
haben glauben dass wladimir putin in
irgendeiner weise ein interesse daran
hat sein gesicht zu verlieren oder nicht
zu verlieren er möchte die ukraine
auslöschen punkt und wir haben zu
entscheiden ob wir die ukraine
unterstützt und herr gysi ein wort zu
ihm
sie sind zehn jahre jünger als ich auch
ich habe erinnerungen durchaus an
zerstörte also an anderen noch
kaputte häuser und so weiter und ich
kann ihnen nur sagen gerade unsere
geschichte gerade unsere geschichte 27
millionen russen ums leben gekommen der
großteil in der ukraine heute leben noch
menschen jüdischen glaubens überlebende
der shoah und wir sollen jetzt sagen
humanitäre hilfe machen wir das machen
jeden krieg vergessen
nicht ablenken am see haben frauen
gerade und über 400 millionen euro
humanitäre hilfe geliefert dass ein
absolutes muss wir machen sanktionen die
durchaus auch unser eigenes land
berühren es gibt keine sanktion den ich
auch durch klick auf unsere bevölkerung
zurück aber dass wir die ukraine zu
verteidigen haben nach unserer
geschichte wo wir dieses land kaputt
gemacht haben ich interpretiere
geschichte in verantwortung für das was
die generation vor uns dort angerichtet
haben gregor gysi ist zehn jahre älter
als sie würde ich sagen und nicht jünger
und sag ich aber ich bin zehn jahre
jünger als er und habe auch durchaus
noch erinnerungen an kaputte häuser und
noch über zehn jahren ein gewaltiger
unterschied lasse ich mich nur ein satz
sagen aber die geschichte verändert
haben sie gedacht 50 geboren ist die die
nato und die eu haben in bezug auf die
ukraine und russland eigentlich alles
falsch gemacht was man falsch machen
können dankbar bald aber es gab keinen
einzigen grund der den angriffskrieg
russlands gegen die ukraine
gerechtfertigt hätte keinen einzigen
deshalb muss man diesen angriffskrieg
auf meiner partei scharf verurteilt es
gibt keine alternative diesbezüglich und
man muss immer sehr eng aber wir haben
verstanden dass ihnen andere beenden
müssen und die deutschen mit so waffen
hillig und weise war aber auf andere art
und weise können wir auch unseren
beitrag macht muss ermittler geben
niemals so es muss ja auch gegeben wenn
man einen frieden will jetzt aber sowas
schützen werden sie nicht sehr hohe
missions- präsidentin ursula von der
leyen mit der wir heute in brüssel
verbunden waren um sie exakt danach zu
fragen die ukraine es soll eben und kann
er auf lange zeit nicht mitglied der
nato werden es gibt die aussicht auf
eine eu kandidatur die wiederum ist für
manche länder der europäischen union
sehr gut vorstellbar auch für die
präsidentin für andere weniger danach
habe ich sie als erstes gefragt also da
von der leyen
aus brüssel ist und die
kommissionspräsident in der eu
zugeschaltet einen guten abend ursula
von der leyen guten namen freuen die
ukraine soll diesen krieg gewinnen die
ukraine gehört in die eu die
kommissionspräsidentin ursula von der
leyen spricht sich klar für einen
raschen beitritt der ukraine in die eu
aus braucht es anschieber vorreiter auch
antreiber wie sie
naja eins ist völlig klar die ukraine
sehen sich mit aller kraft danach
mitglied der europäischen union zu
werden
und wir sehen ja auch wie beeindruckend
sie unsere werte verteidigen mit allem
was sie haben bis hin zu ihrem leben
aber es gilt natürlich auch für die
ukraine wie für jedes andere land dass
bestimmte standards erfüllt sein müssen
rechtsstaatlich wirtschaftlich politisch
um der europäischen union beizutreten
sie kennen das heißt sie kennen die
einwände die natürlich im raum stehen
und nicht von irgendjemandem manuela
groll und olaf scholz treten da gehörig
auf die bremse verweisen erst auf die
west balkan länder die längst dran sein
und sagen in bezug auf die ukraine das
kann sogar jahrzehnte dort schauen sie
dieser beitrittsprozess das hängt ja
auch ganz ganz stark davon ab was der
beitrittskandidat wie die sich verhalten
die beitrittsländer und was sie tun die
ukraine will um jeden preis in die
europäische union das heißt dass ganz
viel motivation als ich auch richtig
anzustrengen und ihre formen zu machen
die notwendig sind und deshalb halte ich
es für richtig dass wir uns folgendes
überlegen wir werden sowieso den
wiederaufbau der ukraine mitfinanzieren
müssen auch andere wie die vereinigten
staaten oder die weltbank um nur einige
zu nennen aber wir werden seinen teil
dazu beitragen und dann ist es doch
sinnvoll mit der ukraine so
zusammenzuarbeiten dass wir sagen ja
investitionen aber gleich mit den
notwendigen reformen zum beispiel gegen
korruption oder zum beispiel für den
aufbau der rechtsstaatlichkeit das will
die ukraine auch ich habe das heute
morgen noch einmal mit präsident
seelands gesprochen und dann hängt es
sehr stark davon ab wie sich dieses land
entwickelt wie sie allein einen
zusätzlichen stabilisierenden faktor das
heißt sie haben unter garantie die
osteuropäer mit diesem plan auf ihrer
seite aber noch mal die frage wie
überzeugt man wohl als fouls wie
überzeugt man immer neue makro ich
glaube durch fortschritte in der ukraine
des wiederaufbauprogramm koppeln an
reformen und zeigen dass sich dieses
land zum positiven verändert wenn wir
uns mal anschauen
die anderen beitrittskandidaten die
slowakei früher die hat ab einem
bestimmten zeitpunkt gesagt wir wollen
jetzt unbedingt der europäischen union
beitreten und hat mit aller kraft die
notwendigen reformen gemacht kommission
hat sehr stark geholfen auch durch
investitionen aber vor allen dingen auch
rat und tat und sie sind relativ schnell
in wenigen jahren dann mitglied geworden
wer am anderen beitrittskandidaten da
sieht man dass der fortschritt nicht
stattfindet im gegenteil zum teil
rückschritt und die bleiben im
kandidatenstatus nicht nur jahre sondern
jahrzehnte das heißt es hängt eben auch
sehr viel von der ukraine selber ab und
was ich bisher sehe ist ein ganz fester
wille diesen weg zu schaffen können sie
sich frau von der leyen denn auch die
ukraine auf einem platz vorstellen der
keine vollmitgliedschaft wäre das hat
auch makro ins spiel gebracht so eine
art privilegierte partnerschaft wie
beispielsweise für die türkei könnte man
ja auch für die ukraine erwecken also
ich finde unseren
beitrittsprozess der ja auch
verschiedene stufen hat absolut richtig
es dauert ja eine weile auch bis man
überhaupt beitrittskandidat ist und dann
werden bestimmte kapitel müssen
erarbeitet werden also bestimmte stufen
ja auch muss man erreichen und deshalb
bin ich der meinung dass dieser weiteres
prozess sich auch bewährt hat und dass
wir daran festhalten sollten
es sind also vollmitgliedschaft
das ist der beitrittsprozess der auf
jeden fall der ukraine wie anderen
beitrittsländern theoretisch in aussicht
steht aber ich möchte mal ganz stark
betonen es hängt von der ukraine selber
ab wie sie am ende dieses krieges den
wiederaufbau schafft bei dem wir helfen
werden oder wie sie tatsächlich dann
auch die reformen umsetzt wie sie die
oligarchen los wird wie sie die
notwendigen wirtschaftlichen reformen
macht und wir dürfen nicht vergessen die
ukraine ist schon relativ stark
wirtschaftlich mit uns verbunden wir
teilen zum beispiel das gesamte
elektrizitätsnetz werk wir haben ganz
viel wirtschaftlicher aktivitäten die
miteinander in den letzten jahren
aufgebaut worden sind dieser prozess
fängt ja nicht neu an sondern wir haben
in den letzten jahren viel auch schon
zusammengearbeitet dazu kommen wir
nochmal frau von der leyen milliarden
sind für erneuerbare energien gestern in
einem riesenprojekt angekündigt worden
länger wartet die welt sind jetzt schon
auf dieses öl embargo gegen russland das
ist lange angekündigt da legt sich
irgendwie immer einer quer in diesem
fall ist es ungarn entschuldigung
bulgarien auch noch wann bekommen sie
ungarn überzeugt dann haben sie viktor
orban überzeugt wir arbeiten intensiv
mit den ungarn die haben objektiv einige
probleme zu überwinden zum beispiel ist
das ein land das keine küste hat das
heißt
flüssiggas über die terminal über die
see geht da nicht das heißt sie sind
angebunden angewiesen auf pipelines und
wenn die das russische öl nicht mehr
fließt dann besprechen wir gerade wie es
gelingen kann über kroatien anderes
pipeline öl zu bekommen und zwei
objektive schwierigkeit die sie haben
sie müssen das öl das rohöl raffinieren
und ihre raffinerien müssen dafür fit
gemacht werden denn das rohöl was aus
russland kommt hat noch eine qualität
als das das ist angesagt wenn das nicht
der technisch etwas ideologisches
dahinter stellen ich habe einen dritten
punkt und über den sprechen wir gerade
intensiv ungarn möchte investitionen
dafür in solarenergie das ist ja
grundsätzlich gut aber wir müssen noch
über die höhe der investitionen sprechen
und da wird sich zeigen ob es
ernsthaftes interesse ist oder ob der
politik gemacht wird wir sind bei dem
was sie vorhin schon zweimal erwähnten
es wird frau von der leyen hunderte
milliarden geben nach krieg nach dem
krieg in der ukraine um den wiederaufbau
zu ermöglichen
da diskutieren
jetzt natürlich auch die deutschen
politiker bereits in welcher form
gemeinsame schulden aufzunehmen wird
schwer kritisiert alternativen haben sie
genannt in ihrem programm direkte
mitglieder finanzierung oder die
europäischen töpfe was glauben sie
worauf wird es hinauslaufen wir reden
eben wieder über einen dreistelligen
milliardenbetrag ja über die
finanzinstrumente entscheiden die
mitgliedstaaten und deshalb gibt da die
kommission keine empfehlung ab sondern
wir haben die verschiedenen optionen
aufgezeigt die kennen die
mitgliedsstaaten auch und die müssen das
beschließen viele hier nochmal deutlich
machen der ganze wiederaufbau ja die
europäische union hat ein interesse
daran und hat auch eine verantwortung
diesen wiederaufbau mitzufinanzieren
wir rechnen aber fest mit den
internationalen finanzinstituten mit
internationalen partnern irgendwie den
vereinigten staaten wie japan g7
überhaupt das muss schon da muss schon
ein großer teil der ganzen welt
zusammenstehen um das zu buchen eine
letzte frage das blanke
gerechtigkeitsempfinden lässt einen
natürlich sagen es wäre so schön wenn
die milliarden aus dem vermögen der
oligarchen der russischen oligarchen
nicht nur eingefroren würden sondern im
nachhinein verwandt werden könnten um
dieses kaputt gesamte land wieder
aufzubauen gibt es da irgendeine chance
finden arbeiten europäische juristen an
der beantwortung dieser frage
mir geht's wie ihnen das reine
gerechtigkeitsempfinden sagt gebietet
dass und ich weiß aber auch dass
juristisch alleine die nähe zum kreml
oder die unterstützung des kreml noch
kein strafrechtlicher oder
strafrechtlich relevanter tatbestand ist
deshalb arbeiten jetzt unsere juristen
intensiv daran das ist nicht trivial
möglichkeiten zu finden in der tat
dieses vermögen der oligarchen das
eingefroren ist auch verwenden zu können
für den wiederaufbau der ukraine ich
finde russland muss seinen beitrag dazu
leisten
wir danken nach brüssel danke ursula von
der leyen für dieses gesprächen danke
danke brenner
und wir haben eine chance nach kiew bei
frau belarus es noch mal zu fragen wie
wichtig wäre es für die ukraine in die
europäische union aufgenommen zu werden
ich denke es ist eine wichtige
perspektive weil für die ukraine für die
heutige ukraine
europäische union ist ein 1 1 1 1 platz
dass selbst das verstehen verstehen des
prozesses was wir sind was wir sein
wollen und ukraine haben für sich selbst
schon entschieden wir sind ein
europäisches land wir verstehen sich
selbst als ein europäisches land und
vieh beitritt zur europäischen union
es ist eine formalität die das aber
symbolisch und politisch
befestigt und die kinder ja ich finde es
ist eine sehr wichtige perspektive und
das ist sehr wichtig die ukraine zu
provozieren die nötigen reformen
durchzuziehen weil wir ja viel arbeit
muss gemacht werden und ihm damit ist
eine neue möglichkeit im raum vielleicht
können wir wenigstens hier noch zwei
stunden hören frau strack-zimmermann was
glauben sie wie sehr wird das wiederum
mal zusätzlich zu schweden und finnland
und diese aussicht die kandidatur für
die ukraine auch in bezug auf die eu zu
erhöhen
die mir putin provozieren also schweden
und finnland treten ja die nato ein und
haben jetzt den auftrag und was sie
gerade gesagt haben er ist militärisch
gar nicht mehr in der lage das zu
verhindern das wird passieren da gibt es
noch probleme
diskussionen mit dem türkischen
präsidenten aber große familie gibt es
immer einen der so ein bisschen von der
seite spielt ich gehe davon aus es wird
gelesen in der nato
das soll vorkommen das muss man
natürlich klären aber da bin ich
optimistisch dass das passiert und bei
der eu da hat frau von der leyen ja
darauf hingewiesen und das gehört zur
ehrlichkeit dazu die ukraine war vor dem
krieg ein korruptes land ich kenne viele
unternehmen auch kleinere anwälte die in
kiel fahren die sind alle wieder wecken
bei sagt was geht gar nicht so ein krieg
verändert natürlich ein solches land ja
und es ist auch so dass natürlich
vorjahren nicht 80 prozent der ukraine
in den westen wollten da gab es auch
durchaus eine menge die russland nahe
waren aber die jungen leute übrigens
auch viele die jetzt zu uns gekommen
sind weil sie vertrieben worden sind die
suchen die nähe zur eu und wir sollten
das fördern aber letztendlich gibt es
spielregeln und die müssen eingehalten
werden weil je größer die eu wert je
klarer müssen die regeln seien weil uns
sonst der ganze laden um die ohren
fliegen ja auch schlechte erfahrungen
zum teil mit polen und ungarn gemacht
und bestimmter hinsicht und deshalb bin
ich aber dafür die perspektive eu muss
unbedingt aufgebaut er das land also
aber jetzt einfacher start sondern
damals 2014 habe ich gesagt dieses
gezerre von der eu und von russland an
der ukraine warum machen wir nicht
daraus eine brücke zwischen der uno sei
2014 da steht doch heute gar nicht mehr
zur debatte jetzt muss man das eröffnen
allerdings müssen wirklich alle
kriterien erfüllt sondern da hat frau
von der leyen rechts sonst geht es nicht
wir sind der größe bei der allerletzten
frage und sie haben schon gesagt dass
die im grunde genommen nicht zu
beantworten ist wie wird eine russische
reaktion darauf aussehen das gleiche
frage kandidatur eu und die bekommen
jetzt mehr atomraketen von russland an
die grenze zu finnland und oder womit
rechnen sie wenn man überhaupt mit
irgendwas nicht mit provokationen mit
geboten die in finnische gewässer fahren
oder mit flugzeugen die über die grenze
fahren der rest ist an und für sich
schon ausgemachte sache also einen
claire waffen in kaliningrad stellen
stehen schon die die militarisierung der
russischen westgrenze die
passierte vor diesem zeitpunkt mit mit
atemberaubender geschwindigkeit
da sind vollendete tatsachen die sind
schon da und das sollte uns auch nicht
kümmern also da muss ich ehrlich sagen
wenn man wenn man immer nach der pfeife
tanzt was könnte putin provozieren und
im vorauseilenden gehorsam schon eine
einen platz an unseren entscheidungs
tischen gibt dann bestärkt man in der
mit dass damit provozieren das mit
militärischen drohungen das mit mogli
androhungen in einem völlig ungeahnten
ausmaß also ich kann mich nicht erinnern
dass die sowjetunion das interview
jemals botschafter einfach aus der
freien leber über nukleare schläge
geredet hätten die die werden die werden
in damals einfach am nächsten morgen
abgerufen und werden achimer irgendwohin
in perm oder in nowosibirsk geworden
dass ich hier einfach die diese lose
zunge dies ist ständige drohen dass sich
dass sich die russische führung an
gewöhnen dass hier jedes wieder mal
abstellen wir sind sich ja auch ab muss
man unterstelle man in erster linie ab
indem sie den kriegen der ukraine mit
krachen verliert und und das auch noch
mal so ein letzter satz wie wir es gibt
keine
schnellere perspektive auf veränderung
in russland als diesen krieg krachend zu
verlieren denn im letzten jahrzehnt hat
dieser militarismus diese sich selbst
definieren über militärische größe über
militärische gloria so einen einen einen
hype seinen innenpolitisches momentum
gewonnen für putin sich darüber die
nationen darüber zu definieren dass
nichts dieses ego des starken militärs
mehr an kratzt als jetzt sich mal ein
blutiges auge zu haben das ergebnis
sollte auf die bundesregierung nicht
immer von dritten weltkrieg rede oder
von atom und dieses narrativ aufriefen
aufgreifen und alle leute hier
verrichten ja bei gericht gründlich
nicht auch und das ist doch wenn es
nicht wahr markus feldenkirchen sie das
mehl nach wir sind ganz schnell bei
markus lanz der heute unter anderem
johannes zu gast hat fdp kollegen von
frau strack zimmermann und dahin wir
jetzt sofort mit schnellen grüßen muss
mich entschuldigen
die kollegen haben auf mich ein bisschen
dass ich das für überzogen haben danke
wir sehen uns in 14 tagen wieder kommen
sie irgendwie über diese zeit herzlichen
dank für die diskussion hier heute abend
und bis dahin
[Musik]